Speaker 1: It is great to have. Back on the
program, Benjamin Dixon, host of the Benjamin
Dixon Morning Show, who is up to some very
important work, I will say, which we're going to
talk about. Ben, always great having you on.
Speaker 5: David, it's a pleasure.
Thanks so much for having me.
Speaker 1: So Christian nationalism,
you know, sometimes there's this shorthand
when when people say, well, what what does
Christian nationalism mean? And you can imagine a
spectrum where on one side you have separation of
church and state, where whatever one's religion
is, it has nothing to do with civil government.
The shorthand that sometimes is used is well, the
opposite side of that spectrum is, for example,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, who says, no, her
Christianity should be exactly what dictates and
determines how civil government should operate. Is
that the right way to think about this movement?
Speaker 5: Absolutely. I think Marjorie Taylor
GREENE inadvertently gave us the perfect lens
to which we need to understand this threat
that's coming from, I would like to say,
my colleagues in the Christian faith. But
there is a sect of Christians who believe
that their specific brand of Christianity should
be what dominates the entirety of society. And
clearly that's a threat not only to those who
choose not to believe or have any other belief,
but it's a threat to those of us Christians
who simply do not believe in the sectarianism
and the tribalism of Christian nationalism.
Speaker 1: Has something materially changed since,
like I remember in the early days of my show,
there would be the televangelists and you would
see a little bit of an inkling of this Christian
nationalism, but you didn't see as much over,
you know, you can't be Christian and vote
for a Democrat preaching politics from the
pulpit. Was it there but less overt
or has something actually changed?
Speaker 5: There's. Well, it certainly has been
there the entire time. There's always been a
faction of the Christian religion that believes
in dominionism. And dominionism is quite literally
the best way to describe it. They believe that
they have the authority to dominate society.
Some of them even go as far as believing
that they should bring do what they can to
expedite the apocalypse, so to speak. That
trend has always been there. But what kind
of control they had inside of the Republican
Party, that was a different question. And we
saw back when I got started, even I got started
around the Jeremiah Wright time, there was this
belief in the Republican Party that they could
capitalize on the evangelical vote without having
to subscribe or bow down to the more zealot
trust form of evangelical white evangelicalism,
to be specific. And we see now that after years
and years and years of getting the votes of these
particular types of evangelicals, that group
has taken control of the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: Can you mention white evangelicals?
Can you talk a little bit about the kind of
racial breakdown of these movements? Because
we've known for a while that, for example,
in the Prop eight era in California, there
certainly are conservative religious values
in black churches. That's right. But is there a
difference in terms of the political application
as it comes to Christian nationalism between
some of these different groups of churches?
Speaker 5: Absolutely. I think back I hearken
back to the statement from Malcolm X that 11:00
on Sunday mornings is the most segregated time in
America. And that's because there's a fundamental
difference between black Christianity and white
evangelicalism, not so much in terms of our belief
in Jesus, that fundamental belief in Jesus is
the same. But you have to take into context. When
black people were praying for deliverance from
Jim Crow, praying for deliverance from slavery, we
were literally asking God to deliver us from white
evangelicals who would lynch us on Sunday morning
and then go to Sunday school. So the difference
really lies in the value of human life in terms
of black people, the willingness to decapitate
the entire message of justice. You think about
the Thomas Jefferson Bible, where they completely
erased any semblance of justice and the narratives
of setting free the captive. They took that out of
the Bible and gave that to the slave, the enslaved
person, because they fundamentally understood that
that messaging would galvanize a black liberation
movement, which inevitably happened anyway.
Speaker 1: You know, I got a call, I think it was
last week or the week before from a self-described
white progressive Christian. And this guy
described his views about a number of different
issues, and they were pretty conservative views.
But what made him a progressive was he doesn't
think any of those opinions should have any
bearing on what government does. So that's an
interesting thing, because sometimes it's not
about I mean, I don't know. You tell me when we
talk about the progressive Christian movement,
is it still conservative? But it says that
that conservatism should be completely separate
from how folks vote or what is it exactly?
Speaker 5: Yeah, there's a wide range of beliefs
in Christianity. I mean, in terms of like so if
we just talk about social issues. There's a large
group of Christians who fundamentally and they
use theology to support LGBTQ rights. So there
is a broad range, but even in the progressive
circles that hold on to conservative beliefs,
there's like you mentioned, the black community
is extremely conservative on a lot of issues. But
where they draw, we draw the line fundamentally is
we don't believe that our beliefs should be used
to discriminate against anyone else. Whereas
Marjorie Taylor GREENE not only believes that
those beliefs should be used to discriminate,
they believe that it should be the fundamental
tool by which we organize society. They don't
believe in democracy anymore. They fundamentally
believe in a theocratic fascist state. And when
we talk about the particular theology, it is a
white supremacist, Christian nationalist theology.
Speaker 1: Hey, when it comes to like the future
of the of Christianity in the context of Christian
nationalism, I think I've seen you either say or I
read in some of the info you sent me that you see
Christian nationalism as a threat to Christians
and Christianity as, as you describe yourself as
a part of that movement. Can you explain that?
Speaker 5: Oh, absolutely. In the clip that's
going viral now, there's a there's a particular
white evangelical pastor who was disgusted
with the fact that black people call ourselves
Christian. And the reason for that disgust is
because he hated the fact that we fight for
justice, we fight for liberation, we fight for
democracy. We fight for things that he feels is
anathema to his particular beliefs. So there's a
clear divide in not only a divide, but we are not
safe. You have to understand anyone. I mean, I'm
sure everyone can contextualize it for history,
like this type of nationalism, this type of
Christian nationalism was the justification for
slavery. It's now being used as a justification
for the bigotry that we're seeing on every front.
So I don't think black Christians are safe at
all. I think we are going to be targeted just
as much as, let's say, the LGBTQ community.
Speaker 1: It's been interesting, I guess.
Interesting. I don't know. There's probably a
different term for it, but it's been notable that
Christian nationalism has grown arguably as much
as at any time in the last couple of decades
during the presidency of a guy who clearly was
lying about his religiosity. Like it's very,
very obvious that Trump was never religious.
Trump was never against abortion. He kind of
contrived all these things in the run up to being
the Republican nominee because Democrats weren't
going to going to make him the nominee. Do you
know what I mean? I don't even know how to ask
the question. What do you make of that? Because
you would think that you would not necessarily
see the growth of this movement when while
they are simultaneously, you know, pledging
loyalty to a guy who is obviously not religious.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it's a it's a really acute case
of special pleading. They are willing to ignore
everything about Donald Trump because they felt
like he was the vessel that could accomplish
their agenda. And in so many ways, he has right.
With all the conservative appointments to the
Supreme Court and through the entire judiciary,
now, with the rollback of Roe versus Wade, he has
been a vessel to accomplish their ends. They did
not care whether or not he was more like Satan
or Jesus. That was completely immaterial to them.
And I think we saw that happen
in that election. And it's also
the last thing I'll say about it is that these
Christian nationalists, you will notice that
they don't use the language of Jesus. They
use the language of traditional values,
and they get to define those traditional values.
So I would argue that it's not only the result of
them wanting to use Donald Trump. I believe they
have the same level of faith as Donald Trump.
They're in the realm of heresy based on their own
Bible. They are looking at Donald Trump as the
second coming of Christ. There's a book out now
that literally calls Trump the second coming of
Christ. I saw that. It's a political opportunism,
and they want power just as much as anything else.
They want political power and economic power.
Speaker 1: When folks talk about how to fight
against this movement, one of the first
things that's mentioned is, hey, you know,
if you're doing any kind of politics as a church,
you should lose your tax exempt status. And
there's this feeling among some that the best way
to fight this is essentially a financial fight,
demand investigations into the nonprofit status
of some of these churches and get them maybe,
I guess, to lose that status, even though it very
rarely happens. There is some hope that if the IRS
does kind of scale up operations a little bit,
maybe this is something that they would look at,
although it doesn't really seem like a
priority. Do you think that that's an
important and viable way of fighting this,
or do you think there are other better ways?
Speaker 5: Well, actually, I don't think it is
not because I disagree with the tactic. I do
agree that if you are going to use tax exempt
dollars, you have to accomplish political ends.
You should lose your Bible one seat, three status.
That's what the law says. Sure. However, there's
nothing that you can give. A Christian more than a
victim narrative if you can give them a narrative.
We're under attack by the IRS. Their donations are
going to go up. So I don't think it's an effective
strategy. I think the more effective strategy is
to really extrapolate a little bit higher because
despite what any Christian believes and their
individual dogma, if they are if they consider
themselves to be a person of good faith, then they
understand that we're going to have to co-exist.
And I know that word has gotten a little kind
of Kumbaya ish. But the fact of the matter is,
is that there is an alliance that has
to be made between people of good faith,
whatever they believe. So the IRS technique
is I don't know if they want to go after that,
that's fine. I think that gives Christians
nationalists more tools to complain about.
Speaker 1: So what are some of the other ways that
individuals, whether they are or are religious,
can get involved in pushing back against this?
Speaker 5: Well, one, you could just call them out
on their own frame, right? I think a lot of times
some of my friends in the atheist or agnostic
community, they they what they would rather
challenge the frame and dismiss the possibility
of God. My suggestion is call them out on their
own BS. Right. There's nothing about Christian
nationalism that's remotely like Jesus based on
the Bible, right? Nothing. It's like Gandhi said,
though. He was bit of a racist. He had this
right. He said that I like your Christ,
just not your Christians. And there's no part of
what is being pushed by the Christian nationalist
that's even remotely kind or just or reflects
the image of Christ. And even if they don't
like the image of Christ, I'm not talking about
our allies in the atheist community. They're
just not good people. I think we can attack
them on their own frame because they can't
even stand up to their own their own test.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to talk about,
we saw the Supreme Court overturn Roe v
Wade. It was very obvious when that happened,
like after your biggest victory, you don't stop.
So so you know, you're going to keep going now.
Lindsey Graham has proposed an outright federal
ban on abortion. We don't know if gay marriage
might be coming next. You know, very far down.
There's this idea of interracial marriage,
although I don't think it's a priority. Oh, Ben,
did I just lose you? Well, we might have lost Ben.
Let's see if we can get Ben back. Oh, no.
Let's see if we can get Ben back. What? What
did we were getting right to the crescendo of the
interview. Let's see if we can get him back here.
Oh, my. Would be really a shame if I
wasn't able to get this question in.
Speaker 4: Hmm.
Speaker 1:
Something must have happened
to his Internet tubes.
Oh, boy. Well, listen, we were coming to the end
of our time. My question to Ben was going to be,
do you expect to see the churches, the right wing
churches get even more extreme now that they sort
of won in a way on overturning Roe v Wade? Are
they just going to be pushing for more and more
extreme things? But we'll have to save it for next
time. Benjamin Dixon has been joining us until we
lost him. Host of The Benjamin Dixon Morning Show.
We will link to all of his stuff. He's doing great
work fighting Christian nationalism. And we will
take a quick break and be back right after this.